i got the first three episodes of season
two and i have to tell you i was dying
when i was introduced to
lead tasso so funny the alter ego ted
lasso jason how much fun did you have
being
mean ted uh it was quite cathartic
it really was um it was it was it was a
fun day of shooting and it's and it's
funny to watch like um
you know further scenes or like early
scenes in that episode which were
clearly shot after doing it
because my voice is a little bit you
know more hoarse i'm like like what's
going on with me there was i must
a cold that day it's like no no i spent
eight hours a day shouting and screaming
and just
bellowing at the top my lungs and you
know some
some of that is just um yeah it's just a
a fun mindset especially especially
trying to do it without
you know ted doesn't curse and so to
like play all that kind of
aggro you know energy without cussing
and you know
it's calling people turd birds you know
instead of
probably other words that you know
professional coaches
uh and college coaches and little league
coaches all all use
uh as a good it's a good exercise for
the brain and soul
honestly i was dying and then of course
watching coach beard be
kind of terrified very nervous of
latassa brendan what was it like for
those scenes for you
watching the tasso was like it's a
it's a dynamic that i get to enjoy a lot
where you know i just get to be
in the background and uh and watch jason
work and he's gonna get a big
head here so um but uh
it's a pleasure it's a pleasure because
not only watching jason work but then
i'm technically in a position where i
can watch people reacting
to what jason's doing and it's like it's
the closest we get
to the in theater feeling of uh of a
live audience
um so yeah led tasso was the most
heightened
and enjoyable uh form of that dynamic
i love it i need like a spin-off show
this seriously like i can't get enough
of it
um jason i've been talking to the rest
of the cast and everybody seems to have
a tactic
for what to do in order not to break
character because these scenes are so
funny for them to shoot
who out of the cast is most likely to
make you break character or do you at
this point just don't break character
uh i try not to i mean
you know my my joke not breaking
a lot when working on saturn live was
that i just said well i didn't find any
of those people funny no obviously i was
laughing because i think it's one of the
greatest generations that i happen to be
you know be a part of and just have a
great you know one of the best seats in
the house for
uh watching people like you know fred
and chris and bill and andy and
forte all you know the whole crew keenan
etc but um
you know a lot of it has to do with the
fact that being involved with the
writing i know
where we're coming from and then also
you know it's just
yeah i think when you're in the moment
you know we we
we um yeah you just try to just try to
play it real and we try to do
you know a lot of jokes that that are
jokes that people just sort of you know
just don't act like our jokes and
they're just kind of like weird little
moments so
uh yeah i think just playing the reality
of the scene as
as corny as an artsy party as that may
sound is
is the best the best help but uh yeah
i'm i'm as capable as anybody on the
show to
start getting giggly especially
especially later in the day when you get
a little punch drunk and you've been up
since 6am
yeah and you know it's like you know
just go to town i have to tell you this
has never happened to me before my
executive producer messaged me early
this morning to tell me how jealous he
was that i was getting to interview you
guys today because
he loves ted lasso so much um brendan
what are you so excited for like
honestly die hard fans to see when it
comes to season two
ah it is you know more um
you know we're just gonna get into it
we're gonna you know we're gonna
give people some different kinds of
challenges than they had in season one
um and yeah i mean there's some specific
stuff i'm really excited about but i
just can't tell you
oh i know you know jason i'm sure you
hear this all the time but people have
talked about how
these characters in this show really
help them get through arguably one of
the most challenging years of their
lives
how much did ted blasto help you get
through last year
oh it was uh it gave me something to you
know focus on
you know uh right the beginning of
lockdown was when we were editing
and uh so i was you know on a zoom
situation with our you know fantastic
you know post-production team
uh you know headed up by kip kroger and
and you know
our editors aj and mel and and just it
it was great to just sort of have like
while this whole
chaos and madness was going on to just
be kind of like all right let's just
focus on these little boxes
and moving moving something forward and
and you know
even before um you know the reception of
the show feeling very proud of of what
we had created knowing how many people
you know gave a darn about it and
and really helped get it to the place it
was and so the fact that people received
it then that was in
the next you know layer of you know help
and then
right into you know writing this the
second season right into
you know creating you know shooting it
it's it's
it's it's been hugely beneficial uh but
but yeah
hearing people slowly but you know
strongly find it and and re-watching it
and sharing it with friends and watching
it you know together you know families
watching it together
uh you know fathers watching with sons
you know people
that connected with it even though they
couldn't be in the same you know
space together but having communal
viewings by you know watching at the
same time or whatnot it has been
uh very very moving for all of us
involved in the show to
to here because it's just nothing
you know i i i it's
nothing you can anticipate um and uh
and it's a a lovely way for you know
something to be received absolutely well
congratulations on this season
i only saw the first three episodes i
can't wait to watch the rest of it
good because there's nine more yeah yeah
awesome
guys
you